[upbeat music]
- How's it going, everybody?
Let's go check out my forge.
I'm Michael Caron
and we are in Tucson, Arizona.
♪ ♪
Got my single burner venturi
forge here.
It's little,
but it does the trick.
I've got this anvil,
which--
if anybody has tried
to find an anvil knows
that getting an anvil
in decent shape these days
is a royal pain.
This little lady:
antique post vise
that my buddy picked up.
I feel like tools that you love
are always ladies.
Boats are ladies.
Airplanes are ladies.
Anything that you want to treat
right and respect: Ladies.
♪ ♪
- Hey, Ethan Lee here.
Gonna show you a tour
of my shop
and all my different
equipment.
♪ ♪
First thing here
is my forge.
I built this forge when I was
about 14, if I remember right.
It's double burner.
I built the box,
insulted, put mortar
and everything on it.
This is something
kinda special to me.
It's whole shavings,
submarine hole.
And I've been making knives
out of it.
Right here is my 25-pound
Mayer trip hammer.
It's been modified to run off
a motor with the side
and a foot pedal.
♪ ♪
- Got a portable bandsaw
there.
Made a little table for it.
The grinder, the 2x72.
It's the knife-maker's
best friend, for sure.
These are decent belts still.
These are all other belts.
There's some decent ones
in there,
but I have a hard time
throwing belts away.
Yeah, so, ready to get to work.
Thanks for coming
on a shop tour.
- So in addition
to bladesmithing,
I also love smoking meat
on this smoker I built.
And when I'm forging,
at the end of the day,
if everything goes
horribly wrong,
I want something
to look forward to.
And today I'm gonna be
looking forward to some ribs.
[sizzling]
So that's my shop.
And if you're ever in town,
come stop by.